[Music]
guys for my money csgo is just the best
eSport Bar None there you go I said it
and when it comes to the pinnacle of cs
competition the majors well there's just
something magical about them that's why
this week's top ten focuses in on the
biggest moments from the biggest stage
now a major moment could be anything
from an underdog run to a sip mechanical
play that still stands the test of time
today so without further ado let's get
on with it with the top ten major
moments in CS goes storied history
starting us off as the 2017 iteration of
Astralis that broke the team's infamous
semi finals curse dating back to when
they were members of Dignitas the
world's top Danish team were haunted by
an abysmal curse simply put they were
unable to make it past the semi-finals
and everybody knew it but that all
changed going into the 2017 elite major
with the help of newcomers glaive and
key RB the Danes were determined to
break their infamous curse how
significant is it that they're getting
those you know overtime wins they're
having those close games obviously this
is a team that's notoriously been called
chokers and isn't about mental fortitude
do you think on that evidence we're
seeing a change that they either loose
very very narrowly are they smash people
when they did move on to the grand
finals they played in a match that many
consider to be one of the greatest major
finals in CS goes storied history this
is incredible
are we going to see it Armstrong is
going to break the curse are they going
to win their first major the first time
they're the finals and their first title
we'll find out as the actions on it
Gabby opens it up takes out beyond the
already
has to stop for more kills and they will
have made it at the full distance nak
silicon a couple decision he goes down
with the Mack 70 car make it happen
finally pressure coming in with the
refract buddies down the form has been
picked up by the pre they get the spray
age of 16 14 against and it's a straw
'less who will be carrying that trophy
home with them
incredible coming into the number nine
spot is the moment the virtus plow came
to a crashing halt that's right it's
with heavy hearts that we harken back to
2018 C League Boston major and the end
of the virtus Pro era coming into the
Boston major virtus Pro were the longest
standing roster in cs:go history having
competed together since Dream Act 2013
over that time they cracked the top a to
the previous 10 majors and were always a
threat to win it all and it'll be 15
exist to come charging in
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a forest he gets the first he
doesn't get us
[Music]
[Applause]
they're just a puppy ladies and
gentlemen put your hands together for
your gear Network Canada ten champions
[Music]
[Applause]
do thick and thin the virtus plows stuck
together and they did have tremendous
success but Pasha biceps & Co were
struggling ahead of the Boston major and
while they were qualified for the new
legend stage they failed to net a single
group stage win and this is a team that
you know the word legend gets thrown
around you saw Stewie they're perfectly
fine but the word legend gets thrown
around for any old reason it's really
losing its value but for these guys like
legend doesn't even come close to what
they've contributed to this scene
whether any of these players retire
whether we never see this lineup again I
don't know but this this community this
counter-strike scene is gonna miss
something when this lineup does go away
shortly afterwards Tazz would leave the
team marking the end of an era that
defines csgo for so many of its fans
taking the number 8 spot on our list is
one of the most unexpected Cinderella
runs in cs:go history that's right we're
talking about ents who came out of
nowhere to make it to IEM katowice 2019
s grand finals that's what's been
against the next team all the way
through this tournament they are
underdogs but they are here to win
please welcome to the stage it dance
[Applause]
[Applause]
everyone had their eyes set on a team
liquid and astralis grand final heading
into the tournament and it's not hard to
understand why Australis were on one of
the greatest runs of all time and Team
Liquid look like the only team that
could stop them but I mean this looks
like the best North American roster ever
formed that is until the North American
juggernauts met a Finnish team named
ents in the quarterfinals and swear
never a serious contender going into the
major but they showed the world that
they were a force to be reckoned with
after taking down the world's second
best team in stunning fashion fans to
take this first map with the
quarterfinals
he's waiting fighting his time to strike
let's try to show with the rated for
later stages of Miraj of that opening
map and it's gonna start them off well
here all are going for the follow-up but
he's got it fast uphill climb against
them it has to be a Herculean effort
it'll each has been found twist all the
remains has got warned about half the
time left of the ball doesn't have a kid
that's the irony life and liquid
to save two more is this the end for
liquid in Katowice I lose 32 kills to
his name's get out another one
when - this could be all she wrote
liquid 20 seconds left
finale chipped in for
[Music]
doesn't blink at something chair
Zeus is run at the crack off major was
both godlike and inspiring which is why
it comes in at the number seven spot on
our list I am NOT going to give up
before I win a [ __ ] major these
hallowed words were tweeted by Zeus
shortly before he was kicked from na'vi
a team he had spent three years chasing
a major title with and one year later he
would do just that
now a member of gambit a team that had
previously struggled to crack the
world's top ten Zeus helped lead his
team to the crack of majors playoff
stage in debate Hobbit out stacks takes
damage from flames to volatile therefore
puts the Nate in position at Hobbit
swings around to close the kill gambit
despite the team of virtus Pro being at
home take full position into the
playoffs the first team to qualify I
wouldn't expect it especially put so
long since we've really seen
international event from them under
Zeus's leadership gambit tryouts
tournament favorites of straw --less in
the semi-finals
before taking on immortals in the finals
we are left with immortals vs. gambit it
is the surprise major two teams that
didn't stand a chance accords the most
of the experts at the start of this
marked by the iconic h e grenade gambit
defied the odds to become major
champions and solidified Zeus's place as
one of the game's greatest in-game
leaders
she can get to make this an instant kill
on the shock across fighters - he's
bound still dreaming God
[Applause]
an unlikely final but worthy of every
groundwater performance from all ten
players everyone had their moments one
more very very very important question
for you you tweeted I will not give up
till a win a mother bit in major you
just did that now what are you going to
do I just say all of place them on lorry
or
and thank him help me and they wore
measure coming in at number six is
arguably the most controversial moment
in major history now before you ask yes
it's the Olaf boost and yes we made our
interns dig up the footage again while
playing on overpass at dreamhack winter
2014 fnatic found themselves down 13 3 2
ldl-c and decided to mount a comeback by
implementing their ace in the hole all
of my sister is still waiting the
patients came coming again spoken coming
out of suite doors while he's here he
sees them down there straight headshot
they have no idea Smith's looking
confused and dazed and it's gonna be a
photo
you gotta be kidding me
oh it finally works and now phonetic
this is the comeback moment for them not
only did the boost gif fanatic
incredibly broken angles to shoot from
but information of the entire map as you
can imagine it didn't take long for them
to mount a comeback as they went on to
take the map in stunning fashion they
make that way to the semies of another
major tournament here
[Applause]
destruction rain down upon ldl-c
[Applause]
but the story doesn't end there the
controversy continued to escalate after
the match as the tournament staff and
teams deliberated on what to do about
the seemingly illegal boost without much
clarity as to why fnatic forfeited their
spot and in turn became the scenes
premiere villains coming into the midway
spot on our list is a feel-good story of
epic proportions
early on in CS gos history ninjas and
pyjamas had to find what being a top
team meant with their incredible 87 and
no run kicking off the csgo era the
swedish powerhouse dominated throughout
2012 and 2013
but when valve introduced the majors the
dominant ninjas found themselves
hard-pressed to win a title with fnatic
poised to overtake the ninjas as the
best team in the world many thought that
the ni P era was dead and gone
heading into cologne 2014 it's not only
gonna be harder I mean I think the thing
that's at the back of my mind is this is
the worst nip I've seen since they
started dominating you know that they're
losing games they look vulnerable
they're struggling the entertained those
people were wrong for a way to equalize
the situation he's gonna be walking up
spots pronax here in the corner takes
him down turns around for the 180 still
15 you know one on two throws had
another grade here cants up another kill
is it happening again
drone access alone that bomb is in the
middle of nowhere he's gonna have to sit
down nobody goes down
touches it it happens again to do any
longer ni P have one Gamescom 2014
ladies and gentlemen 1613 it finally
happens
finally Gamescom 2014 the ninjas fought
and clawed to reclaim their title as the
best in the world
taking down fnatic to finally secure
their first major championship after
taking the tournament ni P would make it
to the next two major grand finals
totaling five major grand finals in a
row a record that still stands to this
day taking the number-4 spot on our list
is the major that launched a new era in
csgo
between devices health issues and waning
individual performances from the roster
overall the danish team struggled early
in 2018 but astralis would go on a
dominant tear after key RB abruptly left
and was replaced with Majewski the
question on everyone's minds heading
into the London major was whether or not
a scroll Asst will be able to carve out
an era for themselves or their recent
success was another flash in the pan for
Danish CS and well they answered that by
embarking on one of the most dominant
major runs of all time it just was well
toward benches yet to move nails now no
mistake about it tacos night nowhere
where I can't
as well as he catches out twists he
could start this off with an ace now
it's crawling for it one versus three
a second apartment they have to block
the pump can they find their way into a
block telling me it's gonna be close
there's no chance it won't be free for
that truck because the starless closed
it down
the party going to Pete holding it now
and there is it
it's finally open James I think I think
this error for a long time all right no
minister
chorus journalist
the Danes would further cement their
status as the best team in the world by
winning two consecutive majors and
becoming the first to win the Intel
grand slam coming in at the number three
spot is a csgo milestone that won't soon
be forgotten a moment that saw one of
the most dominant teams in the world
become the first back-to-back major
champions
2015 saw fnatic dominate competitive
csgo and after winning the Katowice 2015
major the Swedish team had their sights
set on making history by winning the
next one in Cologne one team stood in
their way but not even Kenny s and the
rest of envious could stop the swedes
from making counter-strike history I
agree I mean I kind of feel like NBS has
been slightly more hot today as I
mentioned earlier but then again
phonetic is just an unstoppable force
especially when they get going
I feel like Olaf is gonna be on point I
think that he's furious right now he
wants to prove the fans the crowd
something that he is the board's best
player why would they slow down there's
the flash that's gonna catch creams out
they're gonna push off through and if he
can't gets Robert where's that demon on
last nanosecond kill and look at the
guns
aw bees they're ready to shoot some
ducks as they cross the middle it's
gonna be a challenge and
not in this lifetime he is destroyed six
health then ladies and gentlemen it's
gonna require a miracle and nothing less
for happy to make it out I don't think
this any chance flusher looking to end
[Music]
take that place at the top echelons of
counter-strike history they are by far
the best team in csgo there is arguably
no moment that captivated an entire
region quite like this one which is why
our runner-up spot goes to cloud nine
and their incredible championship run at
the Boston major things look dire early
on for Stewie and Coe as cloud 9 fumbled
their way to an O to group stage start
but the young na upstarts managed to
turn things around by taking down a
couple of legends to qualify for the
majors playoffs and they didn't stop
there the kill almost went down himself
this body picking it up and now it's a
one bust this one Stewie versus candy
the spell of gunfire and straight up in
the air it's doing picking up that kill
519 seconds they're almost out of time
idiot Liam now it's down to Phelps he's
down from the forum side and taco is
miles away me but the kid already picked
up it's gonna be a gaming after clawing
their way into the finals and his
greatest hope would square off against
tournament favorites and onstop of the
super team faze clan no doubt cloud
might have had that miracle run they've
beaten so many great teams that are
above them in the world rankings this is
the final boss this is the face roster
just look at this Talent it is so
stacked but the American squad wasn't
intimidated by the likes of Nico and
Guardian and they played this series of
their lives doing the spraying and now
it's not this good dude OH he's see the
trick three nice let's take down to a
short piece but no grenades he's holding
a slight angle God in his so Fred not
expecting it
skadoodle my Spotify Jonah's got nuclear
war Dilton
play maybe tweet or Josh position that
what if I was gonna show it but at the
touch and he's taking that Tara is not
done with this major yet they stay alive
for one more round
after this round rider going to overtime
or with crowning a new major champion
were handing away a trophy nothing else
is going on he's gonna go back Stewie's
on his own but look at a time
still around we go
it started
all they've got
they came back all the way in what will
almost certainly go down as one of
counterstrikes greatest underdog stories
cloud nine pushed the series into double
overtime and secured n A's first ever
major wind guardian waits patiently as
cloud my scepter push up
[Applause]
a major champion
[Applause]
this has to be one of the most
incredible storylines we've ever had a
North American team in North America
with a major win that is truly
incredible the class vasily is the
strength time and again that they've
shown is something very special indeed
taking the top spot on our list is a
play that simply needs no introduction
no this moment isn't a tournament win
it's not a story upset or a
gut-wrenching failure and he may thought
we were aggressive this is simply a play
that defines what a major should be
it's a jaw-dropping play that brings the
crowd to their feet and becomes edged in
your mind for years to come a play that
showcases what one decision one chance
and some luck can do yes holds eras
jumping off defines the beauty and the
raw hype that every csgo major should
have
here he comes once again the first base
is attorneys gonna hit the ground
there's cold on the safely below steer
with your play unthinkable seems there
on the be apartments they need a huge
play without something I'm never gonna
see ever again ridiculous stuff that's
the most ridiculous thing I've ever seen
well guys that's all we got for this top
ten I hope you enjoyed it and if we did
miss any of your favorite major moments
let us know in the comments below now
that you're still here would you like to
hear my impression of my favorite major
calls Smith's looking confused in days
there's gonna be a follow up headshot
here they come once again a jumping
double for cold how does he do it
unthinkable seeds at the P apartments
those are the only two on this list